- Welcome to our fourth
and final Shulman Lecture
for the semester.
I'm not saying that we
saved the best for last
but I'm not denying it either.
Our speaker today is
Professor Elizabeth Spelke.
She is the Marshall Berkman
Professor of Psychology
at Harvard, where she also co-directs
the Laboratory for Developmental Studies.
She is certainly one of
the world's most prominent
and impressive cognitive scientists.
And in my only hesitation in saying that
is that I'm not sure the
word cognitive is necessary.
Liz is also just one of
the world's most prominent
and impressive scientists.
This is true in terms
of both concrete methods
and abstract deep theory.
Methodologically, Liz has pioneered
new ways of reading the minds of babies
with elegant behavioral measures.
Theoretically, she's used these methods
to transform our
understanding of our own minds
and where they come from.
And she has done this, not just
in one or two case studies,
but for essentially every
primary aspect of our minds
that we care about,
characterizing what she calls
our core knowledge of objects,
space, number, physics, geometry,
social agents, and beyond.
And I think those categories
are very important
but also sort of a
little dry and abstract.
In the context of doing this,
Liz has also studied everything
from food and shadows and maps
to race and accents and kinship
to music and singing,
to a paper in science earlier this year
that looked at infants appreciation
of intimacy and saliva sharing.
That's the first time we
have uttered that phrase
in the Shulman seminar.
In almost any aspect of
these areas and beyond,
you can find her work
both at the foundations
and the cutting edge.
As one person has called her,
she is the "preeminent researcher
"of the basic ingredient list
"from which all human
knowledge is constructed."
And if this is starting to
sound a bit too grandiose,
I will just note that a
profile of her once noted that
she had summarized on
her lab's bulletin board
her current research program in terms of
"blocks and holes, talking
blobs and wet animals."
And I will confess, Liz, I've never known,
I get the other two,
I've never known quite
what to make of the wet animals thing.
But now that I see the saliva sharing,
maybe I'm starting to see that.
Liz has done all of this
while being one of the most positive
and nurturing people in our field.
The list of students she's worked with
is really a who's who of
cognitive science at this point.
And she is a role model for so many of us.
In fact, if you'll permit one
slightly disturbing story,
I've only ever had one negative thought
about Liz in my career.
It was early on and it was my mistake.
When I was a second year graduate student,
I think in 1995 or some
pre-historical time like that,
I wrote one of the first
papers I had ever written,
and for some reason it occurred
to me as it happens to one
that like Liz Spelke
needs to read this paper.
And so I emailed her out of
the blue as a graduate student
and I said, "Hey, I've done
this work on blah, blah, blah,
"and would you be willing
to take a look at it?"
And she responded in about like 10 seconds
by email and said, it was
such a warm and nice message,
saying, "I would love to check that out,
"please send it to me.
"It sounds so interesting.
"I'm in France this summer,
please send it along.
"I'll get you back comments right away."
And I was so excited.
And she never wrote back to me.
And so I thought that
was sort of the genesis
of this negative thought,
that for years, I thought
like, wow, she seemed so warm,
but it was like a con,
she never got back to me.
And then I finally met her years later
and she seemed so nice and I
was hesitant to bring it up.
And then two years after that,
this is like six years
after I had sent this paper,
I got the paper back.
And this is the slightly disturbing story.
That paper had been in the
mail on flight TWA 800,
which, for those of you
who don't remember this,
this is a flight that famously
was on its way to France and
crashed over Long Island Sound.
They recovered the paper
from the bottom of Long Island Sound
and it had been in the custody
of the agencies investigating
the crash for years.
I don't think they found
any causal connection
between the work, though.
So, Liz, I apologize for thinking
that negative thought about
you for all those years.
It wasn't your fault.
I'll end just by noting that Liz has won,
basically, just all of the honors
that our field has to bestow.
Among many others, she's
a member of the AAAS
and the National Academy of Sciences.
She's a corresponding fellow
of the British Academy
for the Humanities and Social Sciences.
She and her work have been
profiled in both the New Yorker
and the New York Times.
She's won the Jean Nicod
Prize, the Kurt Koffka Medal,
the Heineken Prize for Cognitive Sciences,
the William James Award
from the American Psychological Society,
the Distinguished Scientific
Contribution Award
from the American
Psychological Association.
I think most important,
she won a Distinguished Alumni Award
from the New Canaan Country
School here in Connecticut.
But she has not yet delivered
a Shulman Lecture here at Yale.
Please welcome Elizabeth Spelke.
(all applauding)
- I don't know whether to thank you or not
for that introduction.
(all laughing)
On the one hand,
I'm not gonna talk about
any of those lines of work.
If you wanna know about saliva sharing,
you're gonna have to ask me over drinks
or something afterwards, okay?
Second, while I might have been innocent
on that particular occasion,
anybody who knows me knows
that I'm way more enthusiastic
about what I say I'm going to read
than I actually end up
having time to read.
So while I might have been
innocent in that particular case,
you shouldn't conclude across the board
that that's going to be true.
One thing I do have to say is,
I'm, again, coming from
Paris and I am so happy
to be here with all of you.
This is my first real talk,
in-person talk since the pandemic started.
It's been totally fun.
I've had a really great day so far
and I'm very happy to be here with you.
I'm also under strict orders
that I can't go over 45 minutes,
which is one of the reasons
why I'm not gonna talk about
any of the topics that
were on Brian's list.
And also a reason why I've
decided to do something
that I've actually never
done at a talk before,
which is to start with
the final conclusion
so that if my optimistic assessment
that I'm gonna be done in 45
minutes turns out to be wrong,
you won't be missing the
message of this talk.
So there are three general
conclusions to this talk.
The first is that, between
our perceptual systems
and the systems in which we
use our explicit concepts
and form beliefs and communicate
our beliefs to others,
there's an important
level of representation.
It's a level of representation
that I think is often not recognized
in either philosophy or the sciences.
I think certainly when I was a student,
I was taught that there
were two kinds of systems.
In the mind, there were
the automatic systems
that control our
perceptions and our actions,
and there were the conscious,
deliberate, accessible systems
in which we formulated
and expressed our beliefs,
and that the mind divided
into these two parts.
Today, they're sometimes called
things like thinking fast
versus thinking slow,
peripheral processes
versus central processes,
that this is how the mind divides up.
But I actually think
there's an important level
of representation
between those two levels.
I don't deny the existence of
either of those two levels,
but I think if we really wanna
understand how our minds work
and answer some basic questions about
how are we all the same
and how are we different?
And how do children learn?
That it really helps to focus
on a level that mediates
between and remains constant
over all of the changes
in what we perceive and what we believe.
Now, the second general lesson is that,
at this level, concepts
that are highly general
and the capture properties of the world
that are highly abstract,
actually emerge in development
before concepts that are more specific.
And I think this is true,
both when we look over human ontogeny,
and also when we look over
the evolution of life on earth.
If that's true, it implies that
the ways in which infants
and other animals are like us
are not that they share our basic reflexes
or sensory experiences, but
that they share our basic,
our sensitivity to the
basic abstract properties
of causality and space and
time that structure our world.
Those are the ways in which
other animals are most like us.
And I think this also goes
against widespread intuitions
about what we have in
common with our house cats
and or what we as adults have
in common with newborn infants
that we might share
some of their emotions,
we might share some of
their sensory experiences,
some of their reflex actions,
but surely not the basic
abstract distinctions
by which we understand the world.
That I think, is how we
intuitively tend to think about
infants and animals.
But I think this research
suggests that that's not right,
and that it's really the abstract concepts
that are most likely to be
common to us at all ages
and also common to different species,
and hence the first part of my title,
the primordial blessing of abstraction,
which I'll try to unpack
over the course of this talk.
And then the third lesson
goes against sort of the
most fundamental thing
that people were always saying
to me when I was a student,
and then again,
when I started doing
research in this field,
and would find evidence
that some abilities
seem to be innate.
The idea was that
something is either innate
or it is learned.
And if it's innate, then it's not learned,
and if it's learned, then it's not innate.
And that's all of course, true.
But what people seem to often
think followed from that
was that the more innate
knowledge you have,
the less you have to learn,
because all the stuff that you know,
that's innate is not learned.
I actually think that the reverse is true,
that the more innate concept,
well, let me put it this way.
If we lived in a perfect unchanging world,
where throughout the
evolution of life on earth,
the environment stayed exactly the same
and predictable in exactly the same ways,
then maybe it would be true that
the more innate concepts you had,
the less you needed to learn.
But in the actual world
that all animals live in,
the world is changing and it's uncertain.
And in that circumstance, the
more innate concepts you have,
the more of a learning problem you face
because you have to discover
which concepts to call on
in any given situation,
which ones are gonna be useful
and what they're going to be useful for.
And this is what I call the
curse of a compositional mind.
So what I wanna do today
is, my talk is in two parts.
The first part is going to be an attempt
to convey to you in 30 minutes,
what is soon to appear in
a humongously long book,
which covers exactly
one year in human life.
It starts at birth and it
goes to one year of age,
and tries to talk about what I think
the cognitive sciences have learned about
what infants know over the
course of that first year,
especially in the early
part of that first year.
So I'm gonna spend two thirds
of my talk focused on that.
And then I wanna turn to the problem
that I'm working on now,
in which I hope will
someday become volume two
of the next book and the next
and last book in this series.
I wanna turn to the question
of how children learn
and in particular, focus on what I think
is a learning process
that's unique to our species
and that helps account for
how we could be so similar
to other animals at birth in our abstract,
the abstract concepts that
we apply to the world,
and yet find ourselves
on such a different path of development
when we start to grow explicit knowledge.
So to start with what infants know,
let me see if I can get
all this on one slide.
They know that there are objects,
that the world that they have entered
is going to have bodies
in it that are solid,
then that move continuously through space
and that interact with
one another on contact.
And I think they may also,
this knowledge may be
accompanied by capacities
to form mental simulations
of these objects
and their interactions.
They know that there are places
and that places are arrayed
on a surface over which
you can navigate that
that surface, depending
on how it's contoured,
will afford navigation on
some paths and not others.
And with that surface,
as you travel over it,
you can learn how,
what different paths
connect different places
in the space to one another.
Most tentatively, I
think that they know that
there are living beings in the world
with characteristic forms
and characteristic functions
for us and for themselves
that live anchored to this surface,
and their forms and functions
both may be captured initially
by something like shape skeletons.
And now coming away from the tentative
more to things where
there's more evidence.
I think that they know there are agents
that cause their own motion
and by moving cause changes in the world,
and that they move by
pursuing goals efficiently
to bring them valued
and accessible objects.
I think they know there are social beings
who share their experience,
who experience the world as we do,
and who share their
experiences with one another
or with us in states of engagement.
And I think they know
that they have a system
for representing when any of
the entities I just described
congregate in groups or are
arrayed in sequences of events.
They have a system for representing
their approximate numerosity,
a system that they can
use for diverse purposes,
but maybe especially for learning,
probabilistic learning about
the properties of the world
and also making decisions
and planning actions.
So these different
things that infants know,
I think stem from six
different cognitive systems
that I call systems of core knowledge
that have a number of
interesting properties in common.
The most important is that they
center on abstract concepts
that are interconnected to one another.
And here, I've just put pointers
to the distinctive concepts
that I think arise
from each of these different core systems.
But for the rest of the properties,
I wanna take the place system
to quickly kind of unpack them for you.
The second property of these core systems
is that they're limited.
So when infants or inexperienced animals
begin to navigate through space,
they're navigating through
a very rich environment
where they have multiple
systems that they can use
to pick out landmark objects,
to pick out all different kinds
of surfaces, to see colors,
to see shapes, and so forth.
But when they face the task
of determining where they are
and what paths they should take
to get from where they are
to somewhere else in the environment,
they disregard almost
all of this information
and rely on only one thing,
which is the ground surface
over which they move
and its perturbations.
That's an example of a
limit on a core system,
a limit on the things that
it serves to represent.
In addition to being limited,
the representations from the
core systems are shared...
When we look at the abstract properties
that characterize them and
the limits for each system,
we get evidence that they're
shared by other animals,
that it's not only the
case that we see objects
and that other animals see objects,
but we see objects under
the same conditions
and with the same by using
the same abstract properties
that other animals do,
and with the same limits
on what we represent
that we find in other animals.
Now that gives us reason to believe that
these systems are ancient,
that they evolved long before we emerged
as a species in ancestors
that are coming to us
and to other animals.
Now, because they're ancient,
they can be studied in animals,
not only at a behavioral
level, but at a neural level.
And this of course has been
done famously and richly
in the case of the place system,
providing evidence that
navigation relies on
specialized neural mechanisms
in the hippocampus and surrounding cortex
that these mechanisms
are present in animals
throughout their lives.
They were found first in mature animals,
but then also tracked down in development
and found in animals
at the very beginning,
just beginning to navigate
through the environment.
Armed with this information,
functional brain imaging studies
revealed the same mechanisms in humans
providing yet more evidence
that we share common systems
with these other animals,
and also providing
evidence that in humans,
as well as other animals,
these systems are present throughout life.
They're not scaffolding
that you use as an infant
to get cognitive development going
and then throw away as you latch on to
other kinds of concepts
and representations.
Rather, they continue to function
in us throughout our lives
and in other species as well.
Now, because these systems
continue to function in adults.
You can do experiments like
some of the gorgeous experiments
that Brian did generations ago.
You can do experiments where
you catch them in action
in adult minds.
And when you do this,
if you then ask people,
what are you thinking about
while you're in this experiment?
You discover that these systems
are operating automatically
and effortlessly and unconsciously,
but you also discover
that different systems,
representations from different systems
compete with one another for attention.
So again, to use the place
system as an example,
when adults are in a
virtual navigation task,
so they're navigating on a,
you know, with a joystick,
looking at a computer screen
through some environment,
we're able to navigate, to
find our way to an object
in at least two different ways.
One, by using objects in
the environment as landmarks
and marking where we are relative to them,
and two, by using the ground surface over
and its perturbations
over which we're moving.
Now, what you find in adults
is we can use both of these systems,
but on any given occasion, as we use one,
it will tend to suppress the activity
and the neural mechanisms
that support the other system.
So you see a competition between them,
and oh, and by the way,
if you then ask adults,
what were you doing on that trial?
And was it any different from
what you did on other trials?
They generally cannot tell you.
It's not that we're
consciously making decisions
that we're gonna rely on
one system or the other,
it's that they're automatically activated,
but in the competitive
resource limited manner.
Finally, this system
support children's learning
in the case of the spa,
the navigation system
learning the layout of
their local environment,
where things are and how you
get from one place to another.
And there's some evidence in
the case of the place system
that this learning,
and also decision making
about which path to take
through the layout are heavily
influenced by a capacity
that's been found both in adult animals
and also in young animals
for mental simulations of
travel through the environment.
So when an animal
confronts a choice point,
a new choice point that it
hasn't confronted before
of taking either of two different paths
to get to a goal object,
it may well stop at that choice point
and simulate one path or the other path,
and you can track these simulations
if you're monitoring
what activity is going on
in their hippocampus.
And then the ultimate decision
that the animal makes will,
the effectiveness of that
decision can be linked
to the effectiveness of the simulations
that it had engaged in.
And that same process has also
been found in young animals
and also in human adults.
So in the case of place representations,
there is evidence that
processes of mental simulation
enter into our learning about
the layout of the environment.
The reason I qualified
this conclusion here
is that to my knowledge,
there is no evidence
for any direct evidence
for mental simulations in human infants.
So that remains an untested hypothesis.
But the last general thing I wanna say
before plunging into
some more details is that
these different properties
of core knowledge systems
are not just a random
laundry list of properties
that have collected over time.
I think they're interestingly
related to each other.
And that any system that
has some of these properties
is highly likely to have all of them.
And to see this,
let's start with the property
of the ancient origins
of these systems.
And think back to creatures
who lived hundreds of
millions of years ago,
common ancestors to us
and some of the fish
or maybe even fruit flies in some cases
and other animals who
navigate through the world
in some of the same ways that we do.
And imagine that this
ancestor lived in the water
and fed on a certain kind of food,
and the environment in which
it lived lasted long enough
that it was able to
evolve multiple mechanisms
for guiding itself to the sources of food.
First of all, the sources
occurred in predictable locations.
So they kept by representing
their own position
and the distances and
directions of those locations
from their home position,
they were able to use the
geometry of the layout
to navigate to food.
But the food also probably
had a characteristic odor,
chemical composition, which
might have created gradients
in the water that they
were swimming through.
And they may well have
evolved other mechanisms
for detecting the food visually
or detecting the chemical gradients.
But now think about their descendants.
Over subsequent evolution,
the environments changed
and the animals changed.
Some of them grew bigger,
they grew smaller.
Their energy requirements
were no longer met by that kind of food.
They had other kinds of food.
So any mechanisms that
were specific to the smell
or the site or the chemical
composition of that food
would be no longer
relevant to the descendants
from that ancestors on
the way to getting to us.
But for all of those intermediate species,
the euclidean structure of the environment
would've been the same.
The mechanism for
navigating by the distances
and directions of food
sources from the animal
would be useful no matter what environment
that animal was in.
So any system that was ancient
is very likely to focus on
properties of the world that are abstract,
that apply in all environments,
and that are limited,
that don't apply to things
like what stuff looks like,
what it smells like,
the superficial properties
of things that differ
from one environment to another.
But if a system captures
abstract properties,
those properties are
gonna be extremely useful
if they apply in all environments.
And they're gonna imply not
only in all environments,
but to people of all ages,
even as people change their environment,
if their lifestyle brings about, you know,
they migrate or something, they
travel to new environments.
These basic abstract
properties of the world
will apply in all of those environments,
from which it follows that these systems,
if they emerge in infants,
are very likely to stay
present and functional
throughout our lives and
support our subsequent learning
and our subsequent reasoning
no matter what problems we
find ourselves confronted with.
What's more,
the systems are likely to
be neurally specialized
and to operate automatically
and unconsciously,
because if you have a system
that works in every environment
that you're ever gonna be in,
then you don't need to waste
your conscious decision making
resources and figuring out
should I be using it or not?
Yes, you should always be using it.
You should be using it automatically.
However, there is a
problem, which is that,
I guess I didn't put this
property on the list,
but there is a problem that
we have multiple such systems,
but we can only do one thing at a time.
So I think it makes
sense that these systems,
although they're automatic
and operate unconsciously,
nevertheless, compete for resources
so that animals aren't pulled in
multiple different directions
at any given moment in time.
And then finally,
I think these systems may serve
to simulate the entities
that populate the world
that we find in these systems
because they're supporting our learning
automatically and effortlessly.
They're able to do this
from the very beginning,
since they're focusing
on abstract properties
that don't depend on what
things are particularly
gonna look like in one
environment relative to another.
This could be a useful
way to prepare animals
for the world that they're
gonna be encountering.
So that's all the conclusions of the talk.
Now, I can actually get to
the beginning of the talk
and thank you.
And what I wanna do is focus
on three of these systems
to set up the second part of the talk
where I ask how children learn.
I think a lot of how children learn
depends on the ways in which as infants,
they represent objects and
agents and social beings.
Now, I was actually here,
and some of you heard me talk
here before the pandemic.
So I wanna go very quickly
over stuff that we already knew back then.
I'll they talk very quickly
about what infants know about objects,
but then tell you about some
new work we've been doing
on infants representations
of agents and social beings,
but not saliva sharing,
Brian, sorry about that.
Okay, objects.
So what do babies know about objects?
Only really abstract things.
They don't know what
they're gonna look like.
They don't know what kinda categories
they're going to fall into,
but they know that out there in the world,
there're going to be bodies
that move as cohesive holes
that are fully interconnected.
So if parts of them are moving together,
there's gonna be connections
between those parts
even if they aren't directly visible.
And that move on unique
connected paths through space
and over time.
So if an object appears
behind the left screen,
and then an object
disappears behind the left screen,
and then an object comes into view
from behind the right screen
but there was no object
moving between the two,
infants can conclude that
there were two objects
participating in that event.
And if a screen comes
up and covers an object,
infants can predict that that screen,
it's rotating backward.
Infants can predict that that screen
should stop its rotation
when it reaches the point
where that object is located,
even though it's no longer visible
'cause two things can't be
in the same place at once.
And if one object that
red block moves toward
a blue cylinder, that's partly,
that's initially
stationary behind a screen,
and then after it disappears,
the blue cylinder starts to move,
infants infer that the block
will have contacted the cylinder
that they interacted on contact.
Now, interestingly research
by Susan Carey has shown that
if one of these prop,
it's not that infants
can't tolerate violations
of these properties, you can violate them.
But if you violate one
of these properties,
they suspend all their
predictions about the others.
So the properties seem
to be interconnected.
These aren't just separate things
that infants know about objects.
They're connected together and
they rise and fall together.
And all of these abilities
they've been studied in infants
at a variety of different ages.
They've been rebuild in human
infants at different ages.
And very few of them have been
tested in newborn infants,
but all of them have been tested
in controlled reared
animals of various species.
And when tested,
they've been found to be
present and functional
on an animal's first encounter,
perceptual encounter with an object.
Okay, but these abilities
are extremely limited,
and I'm gonna mention just one limit
from a classic experiment
conducted 25 years ago,
or set of experiments by
Fay Xu and Susan Carey
with 10 month old infants.
These were studies in which
infants were shown objects
that very likely were familiar to them
like a shoe, baby's shoe,
that went behind a screen
and a rubber ducky that came out
from the other side of the screen.
And after seeing that event repeatedly,
they were asked in effect
how many objects are behind the screen
by taking the screen away
and alternating trials
revealing either both
objects or only one of them,
measuring how long infants who hadn't seen
the previous events looked
at those two displays
and comparing that to how long the infants
who saw the previous
events looked at them.
What they found is that the
previous events in no way
disposed the infants to conclude that
there were two objects behind the screen,
they seemed completely open-minded
about whether there were two
objects behind that screen
or one shoe that turned itself into a duck
during the time that it was hidden.
Now you could think, well,
maybe this is just a memory problem,
the kids weren't keeping track
of the appearance of the objects,
but Xu and Carey showed
that that wasn't true
because if you measured
how interested they were
in the events where the shoe and the duck
ultimately appeared
relative to events where
the duck appeared on
both sides of the screen
or the shoe appeared on
both sides of the screen,
they were more interested
when there was a change in features.
Also in tasks involving no memory demands
where the question for the infants is not
what's happening when these
things are out of you,
but rather if I lift the duck,
what's gonna happen to the truck?
Will it come with it or
will it stay on the table?
Are these one connected body
or are they two separate bodies?
The infants were neutral
between those two possibilities.
Even as many of them demonstrated that
they recognized the duck
by saying quack, quack,
while they looked at this display
or the truck and so forth.
So it looks like infants
can recognize some objects
and even imitate their functions
without using that information
to answer the question,
where does this object end
and the other one begin,
to track objects over time.
So this suggests that when
reasoning about object motion,
infants are representing
objects as bodies,
but not as kinds with
characteristic forms and functions.
I think a way of thinking about this is
this is a system that's telling infants
what individual things are
out there in the world,
but not how should these
things be categorized
and what generalizations
should I form over those categories?
And here, I think there's a parallel
with the physics engines
that Josh 10 and bound
may have talked about when he was here
in which I know some of you
have been interested in,
or working on that simulate
object motions and interactions.
But let me move on to some stuff
that we're working on actively now.
Infants early developing
understanding of people as agents.
So over the last 25 years or so,
we've learned a fair amount about,
people have learned a fair
amount about infants expectations
about how agents will and will not act.
We've learned that agents
tend to act efficiently
to achieve their goals.
So if an agent consistently
reaches for an object
over a barrier and then
the barrier is removed,
they'll change the
trajectory of their reach
to the more efficient direct
reach for that object.
We also know that infants
will take higher cost actions
to attain goals of greater value.
So if infants see that
the little red agent
is willing to climb a steep
hill to get to the yellow guy,
but only a shallow hill
to get to the blue guy.
Then when the two, the
yellow and blue guys
both appear on a level playing field,
they expect the agent
to go to the one that
they had taken a more costly
action to get to previously.
And finally, we know that
babies expect that
agents will act on things
that are perceptually accessible to them.
And when they do,
their actions will reveal
their relative value
that they give to each of these objects.
So this is worked by you
Yuon, Luo and Susan Johnson,
in which on the two top lines,
you see experiments in which
an agent can see each of two objects
and reaches for one of them.
And under those conditions,
infants infer that the agent prefers
that object to the other object,
contrasted with two conditions in which
the agent can only see
one of the two objects
either because the other is
fully hidden behind a screen
or because their back is
turned to the other object.
And in that condition,
they make no inference about
whether the agent prefers the
object that she reaches for
to the other object.
Only when she can see it,
do they think that that
there's a preference.
Now, these properties
also connect to each other
inferences about preferences
connecting to inferences about visibility,
inferences connecting also to inferences
about the amount of cost
you would take for an action
and so forth.
And they also connect to a
further abstract property,
namely that agents actions
cause changes in the world.
And for this, I wanna talk
very quickly about a study
that I talked about at much
more length when I was here
three years ago
that showed that babies,
when infants of about three months of age,
that is infants who are not
yet able to reach for objects
and pick them up or act
on them systematically,
basically all a three
month old baby can do
if you show them an object
within near reaching distances,
they kinda go like this and look like
they would really like you
to give them the object,
but they can't actually get it themselves.
And if you move it close enough
that they might bump into it,
they actually bat it away, okay?
They can't actually reach,
engage in a coordinated
reach for an object.
So we take infants of that age and ask
if you show them another
person acting on an object
and causing a change in
that object on contact,
do they see that as a
goal-directed action?
And in particular, will they
infer that it'll be efficient?
So in this condition,
Sherry Liu showed a person,
actually, she used to be here
as a postdoc at one point,
Elliot Martin, reaching over a barrier,
touching an object and
the object lights up
and makes a noise.
And then the barrier is removed
and the infant see a direct reach
and indirect reach
alternately for the object.
And the question is which
did they expect to see?
And she compared this condition
to a condition that was made
with exactly the same videos,
differing only in one half second.
For this condition, the video was modified
so that the hands stopped
short of the object
and froze in that position,
and then after a half second
gap in time, the object lit up.
So no space temporal
contiguity between the action
and the effect on the object.
And what she found was that
in the contact condition,
the babies expected the efficient reach
in the no contact condition.
They did not expect the efficient reach.
They had no expectation.
So it looks like
before infants can pick
up an object themselves,
they can strew other
people's actions as costly,
but only if they also
see them as causal, okay?
In the non causal condition
that that effect didn't occur.
Now, those are the
inter-connected abstract concepts
that we see in young infants.
But there's a limit to young
infants agent knowledge of,
their knowledge about
the actions of agents
that was discovered by Amanda Woodward
and Jessica Summerville that
we've been curious about.
It comes up in a simple situation
that works beautifully with
a five month old infant.
Five month old infants, by the way,
are now by then in the
business of picking up objects
and manipulating them.
And these infants are showing a person
who consistently reaches
for one of two objects
presented in constant positions,
in this case, reaching for the ball
which is always on the left.
And then, Woodward asks,
"How are babies understanding that reach?
"How are they representing that action?"
By allowing babies to see
that event repeatedly,
and then reversing the
positions of the two objects
and ultimately presenting
a reach on a novel path
to a novel location, but
where the same object is
versus a reach on the familiar
path now to a novel object.
And at five months of age,
babies expect the reach on the novel path
to the familiar object
and look longer at the other one, okay?
So they see this reach
as directed to the ball
in this case,
not directed to a particular
location in space.
That's at five months.
At three months, they saw
something very different.
The babies were equal,
had no expectation about where the reach
would be directed.
Then later, they saw a
different development
that also seemed to track
the development of the
baby's own action capacities.
This is a case where studied
at length by (mumbles)
many generations earlier,
where babies have to
do one thing like pull,
they see somebody who does one thing,
pulling on a cane in order
to create the conditions
where they can do a second thing, grab,
pick up an object that was
previously out of reach,
but that the cane brought within reach.
And when they presented this
event to 12 month old infants,
the infants recognized
that the goal of the action
was the toy that was out of reach.
By that age, they're also
inclined to use canes
to pull toys into their reaching space.
But at eight months,
before they engage in that
two step action, they took the
goal to be the cane itself,
not to be the toy.
So again, it looked like there was a limit
to infants understanding
of other people's actions,
and that the limits are
overcome at the point at which
the infants themselves
master those actions.
But this raises the question,
how do infants understand actions
that they can't yet perform?
And what Woodward and
Somerville suggested is that
they don't understand them.
They see the behavior of
the agents in these studies
as purposeless until they
get to the point where
they themselves have and
can realize these purposes,
and then they start endowing
other people with them.
But we thought maybe we could
get young babies to succeed
earlier in understanding that
these actions were goal directed.
And we now, as Brandon Woo and Shari Liu,
and our first attempt to do this
focused on the same Woodward situation
that I just described with
three month old infants.
And we just did one thing different.
Based on the last study I told you about
that Shari had performed,
we had a person reach
for one of two objects,
the bear or the toy,
but always consistently for one of them.
But at the point at which the
person contacted that object,
both objects lit up, okay?
And the thinking was,
well, we know that action
at a distance doesn't work.
So touching this, the
babies shouldn't think that
that will have a causal
effect on this object.
But they should think
it'll have a causal effect on that one
and maybe that would lead them to succeed
in a Woodward experiment.
So we then switched the locations
to see what would happen,
and I fully expected that
this study would work.
And this is the point at which,
this is what I'm in
this business for, okay?
I was dead wrong about that.
The babies taught me something.
They were looked absolutely
equally at the change in object
and the change in location.
They had no preference
for one over the other.
So I needed to rethink
what was going on here.
And it seemed like there
were two possibilities,
probably maybe more than two,
but these were the two that we focused on.
One is the Woodward,
Summerville, possibility.
Babies are just seeing these movement,
the people as engaged in aimless,
purposeless, goalless, movements, okay?
But it seemed like there
was a second possibility,
maybe in the same way that
babies use core knowledge of objects
to represent individual objects,
but not kinds of things.
Maybe they use core
representations of agents
to represent individual actions
without understanding that
there are kinds of actions.
There are acts of navigation
that serve to take you
from place to place.
And there are acts of manipulating objects
that serve to get you
to particular objects
that have particular affordances
that you wanna capitalize on.
Maybe they don't have that second level,
in which case they might perfectly
well think of this person
as acting in a goal-directed manner,
but be open to the
possibility that that goal
could be either an object or
a location in space, okay?
So to distinguish those possibilities,
Brandon and Shari ran
two more experiments.
Here's one of them.
This experiment involved
familiarizing infants
with reaches to one object
at two different locations.
So for some of the infants,
here's what the familiarization was.
This person always reached for the bear,
but on alternating trials,
the bear appeared in the
middle of the display
or on the left side of the display.
Across different babies, we
varied which object was the goal
and whether it was on the left
or on the right and so forth.
But they repeatedly saw that
the guy was going for the object
regardless of which of
two locations it was at.
And then they were tested with that object
in a completely new location
that had never appeared before
versus the other object which
had never been reached for
in one of the two familiar locations.
So that's the Woodward situation,
but with information that it's the object
and not the location that matters.
And in this case now, we
see the Woodward effect.
We see the infants expecting
a reach to a new location
for the familiar object
to be more similar to you,
they deem that to be more similar
to what they were seeing before
and therefore less newsworthy,
and so they look at it less long.
Now that could be for
either of two reasons.
They're three months old.
They've been looking at
events in which other people
reach for objects and pick
them up and manipulate them.
That's how they get all
this nice motion information
about objects most of the time.
So they could be predisposed to learn that
reaches tend to be directed
to objects, possibility one.
Or possibility two, they could
be completely open-minded
and be equally ready to learn
that reaches are directed
to locations in space.
So the last experiment tested for that.
To test for that,
we have to have reaches to one location,
but two objects that can
appear at that location,
and then we need a third novel object
which is only gonna appear at test.
And at test, you can trust
reach to a familiar object.
I previously reached for
object at a new location
with a new object at the old location.
And now we see an effect at least as large
of learning to expect
a reach to a location
as learning to expect a
reach to an object, okay?
So I conclude from this that
infants can quickly learn
at three months that a
person's goal is either
to get to a particular object
or to get to a particular point in space.
And what they learn depends
on the nature of the evidence
that they're getting.
But before they learn that,
they represent other people's
actions as goal directed.
They know this action has a goal.
They just don't know
which of two goals it is,
and they need to get
information about that.
But there are limits to,
interesting limits to infants knowledge.
And I wanna talk about one,
using experiments on 15 month old infants
that gets to issues about
experience and mental states
that I know from our
conversations today and yesterday
that many of you are interested in,
and also I'm puzzling over
these experimental results now.
Okay, these are studies
with 15 month old infants.
And the first of them,
they both ask what do
infants understand about
other people's mental states
when those people are
viewing the same array
that you're viewing but from
a different perspective?
So here's a situation where
infants were first shown.
You don't see this here,
but they were first shown that
there are two photographs of faces.
By the way, all of these studies,
including the ones I just told you about,
were conducted over Zoom
during the pandemic.
This is all new work.
And most of them are not published yet.
I'd love, you know,
people's reactions to them.
But initially, they see
just the two photographs.
So they're in view for
this person, this actor,
and also in the infants view, of course.
And then the occluders come down,
and the occluders are placed
so that one of the objects is
hidden from the baby's view
but visible to the actor,
and the other is the reverse.
And the actor now points
to either consistently
to the object that he can see
or to the screen covering
the object he can't see,
which of those two he points to
is counterbalanced across infants,
but infants consistently see him doing one
or the other of those actions.
And the question is, how do
they represent that action?
Do they represent it that
he's pointing to the screen
that I'm looking at,
or do they represent it as
he's pointing to the picture
that he's looking at, okay?
And to get at those two distinctions,
after that familiarization,
the person moves to the
other side of the room
so his perspective and the
infant's perspective coincide.
And now, depending on which perspective
they attributed to him,
they would see one or the
other of these events as novel.
And in that situation,
this is the event that corresponds
to what they saw before.
They see this one as more
novel and look at it longer,
providing evidence that
they do take account
of the visual access of the
other person to the object.
We show this in this study at 15 months,
it had previously been
shown by Luo and Johnson
at much younger ages,
at three months of age
using a simpler situation,
but logically testing
for the same ability.
So that's something,
this is a case where they seem to succeed
in distinguishing their own mental state
from that of another person.
Contrast that with this situation.
We've got the same guy,
we've got the same pictures,
but now instead of a picture
being either visible or hidden,
a picture is either
upright or upside down.
And one of the two pictures is upright
and the other picture is
upside down to the actor.
And the actor's action
is to take the picture
that's upside down to him and turn it
so that it's right side up to him, okay?
And the question to the baby
is, what's this person doing?
Is he taking a picture
that he sees as upside down
and making it right side
up as I just described,
or is he taking a picture
that's right side up,
namely what the baby sees,
and turning it so that it's upside down?
And in this situation,
they do the egocentric thing
and represent, you know,
the evidence is that
they generalized to this display
and look longer at this one
as if they represented him
as taking an upright picture
and turning it upside down,
what they saw from their perspective,
not the agents' perspective.
So as old as 15 months,
infants don't seem to
infer that agents actions
reflect their experiences of the objects
that they're acting on.
They depend on the
visibility of the objects
that they're acting on,
but not on the ways in
which they themselves
are construing that object as
right side up or upside down.
I'm not gonna show you any more data,
but we've done this
experiment multiple times
using different variations on this method,
and that's consistently been
the finding that we get.
We don't yet know why this is.
We don't know whether this is a...
There's one thing that's
different about this case
from the gold case,
the location versus object
case I described before,
which is it's not the case,
it seems like it's not the case that
they understand this guy's got experiences
and that experiences can differ,
but they don't know what his
specific experiences are.
If that's all that was going on,
then they should be equal
between these two events
as they were between the
place and the location.
And that's not what we see here,
but we don't know what is going on.
One possibility is that
kids are just locked
into their own view of the world.
I think we have evidence against that, but
I won't talk about it now
since you're looking at
your watch, which tells me,
oh, no, that's terrible,
and I haven't gotten to
core social cognition yet.
Okay, I have to go faster.
All right, nevermind.
There's at least two possibilities left
once we rule that first one out.
One is that they don't have a sense of
other people's experiences
at all, only of their own.
I think that's not gonna
turn out to be true,
but it's possible given these data.
The other possibility is
that they understand that
experiences can be variable,
but they do not yet have
the means for determining
how they're going to vary for other people
relative to how they
will vary for themselves.
And in the absence of that information,
they fall back on a regularity
that's actually useful
in many circumstances,
which is that very often,
different parties observing the same event
will have the same experience.
We're in a sad movie
together and I'll feel sad
and you'll feel sad as well.
And infants may be relying
on that as a strategy
while waiting as maybe
the pre reaching infants were waiting
for more information to disambiguate
what the experiences should be.
But that's as far as I can go with that.
Now, I wanna turn to the
studies of social beings,
and I'll try to get
through this super quickly
so we get to how children learn.
Okay, three findings
very quickly on one slide
suggesting that there's a distinct system
for representing social beings.
Infants are highly sensitive to faces
that are looking at them,
when peoples change
their facial expressions
and their facial movements,
they tend to imitate them,
when people are looking straight ahead
and then turn to the side
to look to an object,
they will shift their
attention to the same side
that the other person has
shifted their gaze to.
These abilities are all
shown by non-human primates,
as well as by human infants,
suggesting that this is an ancient system.
And I think these
findings also suggest that
the system centers on
interconnected abstract concepts
of social engagement and
shareable experiences
that occur in states of engagement.
But core social knowledge is limited.
Infants up until about 10
months, nine or 10 months of age,
like people who imitate
their social gestures
and their emotional expressions,
and they'll tend to smile at them,
but they're completely unmoved
by people who imitate
their actions on objects.
Infants also tend to view when
other people imitate them,
they view that imitation as social
if it involves purposeless
actions like waving your hands
or jumping up and down,
but not if it involves
instrumental actions on objects,
suggesting that infants
can represent a person,
either as an agent or as a social being,
but not as both at the same time.
They can't represent one
action as simultaneously social
and object directed.
And that may be why until
about 10 months of age,
infants don't seem to have
any notions of actions
that are both social and instrumental,
like gift giving or
competition over resources or
cooperation or helping.
So it's an ancient limited system,
I think, distinct from ancient system.
And that raises the question,
does it support infants learning?
And this is the last experiment
I will tell you about.
Well, actually, I guess I have
a slide that leads up to it.
There've been lots of
studies that have shown that
when you present babies with characters
that they don't know,
so they're just third party observers
to social interactions
among other characters,
they expect characters
who imitate one another
to affiliate with each other,
they expect characters who comfort younger
smaller characters making
crying baby noises.
If two adult characters seem
to comfort the same baby,
they expect them to
affiliate with each other.
But what wasn't revealed
by any of these studies is
what's the function of these abilities?
And might they guide infants learning
about their own social world?
And that's the question
that Ashley Thomas,
who also gets all the credit
for the saliva sharing studies
that I won't talk about
has been exploring with
Rebecca Saxe and me recently.
Here are some studies over
Zoom that she has conducted.
Now, for these studies,
she first works with parents
and gets parents to make
movies of themselves
using their webcam in which
they're staring straight ahead
and then making nonsense noises
and looking to one side or
looking to the other side.
And then she takes these movies
and digitally manipulates them
to add puppets to the movies
so that she can present
infants with a movie
on their laptop screen at home
in which their parent turns to a puppet.
The puppet says something to the parent
and the parent imitates the puppet
by repeating what they said.
So the structure of the
study is there's two puppets,
parent imitates one puppet,
does not imitate the other puppet,
and then the parent goes away.
The two puppets are left,
they move their mouths in synchrony,
and the baby hears,
hi, Brian, how are you?
And the question is Brian
being the name of the baby.
The question is,
who does the baby think knows their name?
Is it the person that
their parent imitated?
So the full design of this study is
every baby has run
through this study twice
with two different adults
and two different sets of puppets.
One of the adults is their parent,
the other adult is the parent
of another baby in the study.
They get to see the name calling
and they also get to see control events
where puppets dance to music.
There was never any
differential looking at the,
during the control event,
so I won't show you that.
I'll just show you
they're looking to the
puppet who called their name.
And what you see is that
when that puppet had been
imitated by their own parent,
they looked to that puppet
when they heard their name being called.
But when they saw a puppet
who had been imitated by
another parent, they did not.
So it looks like
they're making an inference
about who's connected to them
from information about who
is connected to their parent.
But what the study didn't yet tell us is
what kind of inference are they making?
Is it about a trait or is
it about a relationship?
This person is part of my social network.
So to get at that,
Ashley's done more studies.
I'll tell you just one
of them, where again,
you have a parent condition
and a stranger condition,
but in addition to having conditions
in which they see puppets who,
experiments in which they
see puppets who face them
and call to, and hear a voice
calling to them by name,
there's a comparison condition
in which they see puppets
who face away from them and hear a voice
calling the name of another
baby in the study, right?
So if they just think these puppets
are more likely to be friendly,
you should see the same
effects in the two conditions.
But if you think it's really about them,
you'll see different effects.
And what she in fact gets
looking both at first looks
and also total looks, oh,
I'm gonna be shut up soon,
- [Woman] It makes me be the bad puppet.
- Yeah, okay.
Is that the only effect is
when they've seen their parent,
the puppet imitated by their
parent calling to them,
not calling to anybody else.
So, final study,
is this only about the baby,
is the baby only concerned
who's connected to me
or is the baby also concerned
who's connected to the
people that I care about?
Last study, I'll tell
you about, I promise.
So to get at that,
Ashley did one further study
where she now begins with two puppets,
one of whom calls the baby by name
and the other dances in an
equally engaging fashion.
Babies are equally interested
in these two events,
but shows no sign of individual
recognition of the baby.
And then they see events in which
an adult expresses distress to
the two puppets are present,
they turn toward the adult.
And the question is,
who does the baby think
is gonna comfort this adult in distress?
And the baby is run
through two experiments,
one in which the adult is their own parent
and the other in which the adult
is a parent of another baby.
And as you can see, when
it's their own parent,
they expect the parent to
be comforted by the puppet
who knew their name,
not by the other puppet.
So it looks like they're not only learning
who's connected to me,
but what are the contours
of my social world?
They're starting to learn that in infancy.
So I think what we have here
are three distinct and limited
but unitarian abstract
systems of core knowledge,
a system focused on
objects that move on agents
that act and on social beings
that engage with one another
and share experiences.
I think we also see evidence that
infants don't readily
combine these systems,
even though two of the systems at least,
focus on the very same individuals,
but when an individual
is acting on an object
that engages one system
when they're engaging
with another individual,
it engages another.
But children's fast and flexible learning
can't depend on these systems alone
because they're all
shared by other animals,
and other animals don't learn,
don't undergo this
explosive cultural learning
that you see in children
after the first year,
and because core knowledge is limited
in the ways that I've already described.
So that then raises the question,
what accounts for infants
uniquely human learning?
And clearly, I don't have time
to address that question now.
I have slides addressing it.
I did not as,
this is not the first time
this has happened to me,
that I've confidently thought
I would be done in 45 minutes
and I wasn't.
But let me just say that
I think we see hints of an answer
if we look at another developmental change
that occurs over the first year of life,
and actually starts before birth.
And that is that over the
course of the first year,
children learn a great deal
about the language of the people
in their social world.
They learn what it sounds.
They learn about language at
all levels simultaneously.
They learn about its phenology.
They learn about its prosody,
but they also learn the meanings of words,
starting with recognizing their own name
at about four months of age.
They learn the grammatical distinction
between function words and content words.
And they know that they
come to discover that
content words refer to
things in the world,
whereas function words pick
out the relationships among,
refer to relationships among those things.
All of this they learn
before they start to talk.
And also before they start to talk,
by learning these things
about the language
that people are speaking,
they learn things about those people,
and they learn things about the world
that those people are speaking about.
About the people,
I think they learn that
they are social agents
whose actions can be
simultaneously social and agentive.
And I think they learn
this when they hear people
saying things like look at the cup,
look at the bottle.
Look is inviting the
child to engage with them
and sharing experience,
cup or bottle is inviting them
to share an experience of an object, okay?
I think this brings a
new conception of people
and their mental states,
but it also gives children
an extremely useful tool
for learning about the world
because people are agents
and therefore speak efficiently,
and they are also social beings,
and they therefore speak relevantly
and informatively and helpfully.
And whether people are
speaking to the infant
or to somebody else or to themselves,
when they talk,
they make distinctions
in what they call things
that reflect the distinctions
that they think are worth conveying
and relevant in the situation
in which they are in.
So if in an experiment by Xu and Carey
where a 10 month old baby would normally
not be able to tell you whether
there's a cup, you know,
a shoe on one side and a duck
on the other side of a screen,
when they hear somebody calling to them
and labeling those objects
with different words,
they'll infer that there's
two different objects there,
even if they've never seen anything.
Persons just looked into a box and said,
look, a blickit, atoma.
They'll infer that there
are two objects in that box
because you wouldn't go to
the effort of using two words
if you were only
describing one thing twice.
So language becomes
an incredibly useful source
of information for children
to discover what the
cultural distinctions are
in the world that they're living in.
And I think this is the beginning hint
to how children come to learn
so fast and flexibly
about the particular
environments they're in,
even though the core knowledge
that they're equipped with
is utterly uninformative
about the differences between
one environment and another,
since it only centers on
these abstract concepts
that apply in every environment
in exactly the same way.
And I think with this learning system,
we get engaged in a process that leads to
the situation we find
ourselves in as adults
where the vast majority of
the things that we know,
we do not know from our direct experience.
We know from other people.
Either people we know directly
or people who reach us
through news services
or social media or other things.
I think this is both our
greatest gift for learning
and also an extreme potential
source of vulnerability,
because we're going to learn most readily
from sources that we trust,
and if we don't all
trust the same sources,
that can bring us lots of problems.
And then the parting hope of this talk
had I been able to give
the last third of it was-
- [Woman] We're going for an hour now.
- Okay, I'm done, I'm done.
I think maybe if we understand
all this stuff better,
we can start to deal with
some of those problems.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Thank you.
(all applauding)
- Oh.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Woman] We have time
for one or two questions.
- Hi, I have a question about
running the studies with
the babies over Zoom.
I actually used to work
in Karen Winn's lab
before it shut down.
So that's pretty interesting to me.
But I remember learning
in one of my classes that
some things can't be learned on a screen,
like a baby can only
learn to differentiate
the phonemes of a non-native language,
like from a speaker,
not from watching a TV
or watching a movie
or someone on the screen.
So I'm wondering if there,
are there other limitations
that you've encountered
that cannot be learned through the screen?
- That's a great question.
The condition, the study
that you're talking about
is actually really interesting.
It's a language learning study,
and kids are exposed to a Chinese speaker,
and they either have the Chinese speaker
come into their house and
talk to them directly,
or they see a video of the Chinese speaker
who's gone into somebody
else's house and talked to
the people there.
And there's no question that
the non-interactive video
led to no learning.
Just like children don't learn language
from the radio,
they don't learn language
under that situation.
What we do over Zoom though,
is interactive video.
So there's a real experimenter
there who talks to the baby
at the beginning of the study
that mom is involved
in setting up the study
and mom is conversing with
the experimenter at that time.
The baby gets to see all of that.
These babies also were being
tested during the pandemic,
which means they're interacting
with grandparents over video
and other family relatives.
It was really the ideal
time to run a study.
But I have to tell you,
I was very pessimistic when
we started working with Zoom.
The reason we started working
with Zoom is that there were
grad students in my lab who
were highly optimistic about it.
And they talked me out of
my pessimism and, you know,
and so we tried it out.
But I thought there were a hundred reasons
why these studies wouldn't work,
and you've mentioned one of them.
Another reason why I thought
they wouldn't work is that
the environments would be so variable
and full of distractions.
We're testing kids in their kitchens,
there's dogs running around,
the phone is ringing.
I mean, you know, all kinds of,
and we're measuring looking time.
I thought this will never work.
It works so well.
The babies are so much more
relaxed in their own kitchen
than they ever were when
they came into my lab,
and we went into the
sound attenuated rooms
and we turned the lights down
and they would look around like,
what kind of weird environment is this?
And the parents would sometimes
look a little ill at ease.
At home, everybody is relaxed.
The kids are watching the
videos, it works super well.
And we haven't yet found a situation
where we can run the tests at all.
That hasn't worked as well on video
as it used to work in the lab, generally.
For most of our studies,
we never wanna go back.
However, there are things we can't do.
And one of them actually was a
study that was maybe going on
in Karen's lab when you were still there,
looking at whether
presenting kids with plants.
I really wanted to do these studies,
present kids with plants and see
whether they would
distinguish plants from art,
you know, living plants
from inanimate artifacts
by their forms and functions.
And for that, the outcome
measure that Karen used was
a latency to touch an object.
Would they be more
hesitant to touch a plant
than to touch an artifact?
And that, I don't know
how to do over Zoom.
So we haven't been able to run everything,
but I think you're absolutely right that
kids are predisposed to learn from people
that they feel socially connected to.
It's just that in the pandemic era,
you can achieve that
with interactive video.
Yeah.
- Hi, thanks for the
really wonderful talk.
I just wanted to ask a question about
the neonatal kind of
imitation that was featured
several times in your talk.
There's some like recent
work that suggests that
there are alternatives
to the imitation theory
for the neonatal work.
Like one of them being that like
for very young babies and neonates,
that they tend to make
stereotypic movements.
And when they see a
human and they're excited
and they're more likely
to make those gestures.
So, you know, those work,
they haven't been reliably replicated.
And like, theoretically,
there has been some lots
of interesting papers
that discuss these alternatives.
I mean, I don't think from the
core knowledge perspective,
like it doesn't make a,
my perspective, it
doesn't make a huge impact
to the extent that you see
this in other primates as well.
But I just wonder if,
and of course, argumentation
plays a huge role in development.
I just think maybe a little bit later.
- Yeah, so you're,
are you talking mostly about
the current biology paper
that came out like four,
three years ago?
- Yes, hays and
- Yeah.
- there's a also-
- I don't read that as a non replication
of the imitation studies.
What the original imitation
studies had shown,
this by the way, is all
work by Andy Meltzoff,
who has a nice reply to
that current biology paper
in developmental science.
But what the original imitation
studies had shown is that
not that infants are
motorically capable of
precisely imitating what
someone else does, not at all,
but that if you give them enough time,
they will attempt to
reproduce as best they can
the movements that they saw.
And they will not only
do that immediately,
they'll do it after a delay of an hour,
and they'll do it after a delay of a day
if they see that same person again.
Now, what was done in
the current biology paper
is they saw, the babies
got to see a single person,
they did one gesture,
they gave the baby, I
think, a minute to respond,
maybe 30 seconds, not very long.
Then they did a second gesture,
then they did a third gesture,
then they did a fourth.
Different gestures each time.
That had never been done
in the original imitation literature.
What they reported is that
babies imitated all the gestures,
but they didn't imitate it
in that first 32nd window.
It would take them longer to
produce the gestures over time.
And what Andy Meltzoff has argued is
it was because they used that method
that what they found at the end was, yes,
we see all these gestures,
but they're not immediately
following what they saw before.
And Andy agrees, it doesn't
occur immediately after.
But he argues that it does occur,
and the paper where he argues this
draws both on the data from human infants
and also on data from studies
that he wasn't even involved in
that were conducted with
monkeys and with chimpanzees
that showed the same effects.
This very slow, delayed,
partial reproduction.
By the way, what I think is
interesting about imitation,
for years, I was puzzled by imitation.
Why are babies doing this?
I think the reason that
they're doing it is
it's the one reliable signal
that they're able to give to someone
that they're attending to that person,
and they're motivated to engage with them
in the moment, right?
They can't use language to say that.
They don't have any
specific cultural knowledge
that they can draw on to
indicate that to somebody.
The one thing they can do
is copy somebody's action
and it's something that's very unlikely
to happen simply randomly by chance
if you weren't both
attending to that person
and motivated to signal
your state of attention and engagement.
So that's all, I think that
the imitation is about.
It's been eliciting
controversies though for
40 years now
since the original
reports in the seventies.
And it's clear that these
are very subtle phenomena
that you see early on.
I wouldn't put a lot
of stock on this being
full-blown imitation,
but I do think it's saying
something about a baby's effort
to signal to somebody that
they're engaged with them,
maybe in the same way that
these kind of movements
that a neonate will engage in
might be an effort to signal
I'd really like to be able
to reach for that thing
even though I can't do that right now.
- [Woman] One last question from Joanne.
- I'm interested to hear you
say a little bit more about
the special role that language plays
in sort of human cognition
'cause we've talked about all
these different core systems
and they're sort of separate
and we can't use them at the same time,
but then you were saying
something really interesting
right at the end
and I wanna give you a chance
to say a little bit more
about this.
- Thank you.
- About how language is an interesting
sort of integration of
some of these systems.
And it seems like really plausible for me
when it comes to like
maybe object and social stuff.
But I was wondering if, yeah,
if other systems get integrated
by this sort of language process as well,
or, yeah.
- Yeah,
that's actually what my whole second book
is gonna be about,
because I think there's
many, many cases, not only
infants developing
understanding of other people
or infants developing
ability to categorize objects
as instances of kinds,
which are the two things
that I think we see
infants using language for
at the end of the first year,
but also other abilities like
their discovery of the natural numbers,
their discovery of other symbol systems
and developing abilities to
communicate with other people
by means of spatial symbols, for example,
of the sort that will
eventually figure in maps,
and reading, and pictures,
and things like that.
So, yeah, I think there's, you know,
there are many domains,
as far as I can see, actually,
in every domain where you
see children's knowledge
taking off before they get to school
without anybody instructing
them in anything,
it looks to me like it
it's associated with
changes in their language.
Theory of mind is another
great example of that.
So then your question,
what is it about language?
Now, initially, I thought that
the primary feature of language
that made it such a good tool
for learning about the world
was that it was a compositional system.
So where once you know
the meanings of words
and you know the grammatical
structure of a sentence,
you get the meaning of
the sentence for free.
So if a child knows that a word, you know,
when they hear it expression like
look, Lori, a duck, okay?
If they know the meaning
of the word, look,
if look indicates for them
an invitation to engage
and share an experience
and it's directed at a specific person
so they know it's for them,
and it's followed by a duck,
and they know that a
duck refers to a kind,
an object, you know,
at least this individual object,
if not yet a kind of object,
that then if they hear this as a sentence
expressing a specific thought,
the thought has both social content
and its object directed, okay?
So it's both,
and I think that suggests that
it's reflecting a mental state
that's both phenomenal and intentional,
and they're getting that
from the combinatorial
properties of language.
But I now think actually,
there's another related aspect of language
that might be just as
important, which is that
babies seem to already know early on that
they can engage with other
people to share experiences,
experiences of emotion, of action
with imitation and things like that.
But I think what happens at
the end of the first year
is that they come to discover that
they can share experiences that
cut up the world more finely
than just experiences of an object.
They can share experiences of an object
under a particular description.
So for example, when a
person says to a kid,
look at that dog over there,
that's our neighbor's dog,
or look at that dog, that's Fido, okay?
They're using two different words.
Now, if babies expect
people to be efficient,
they don't expect them to
use two different words
to convey the same experience.
But they're talking
about the same objects,
so they must be using two different words
to convey two different
experiences of that object
that can be shared with the child.
And I think this may be
really, really important for learning.
Think about how you
could teach somebody that
the stars up in the sky are enormous suns,
you know, as large or larger than our sun
and very, very far away.
You could point at a star all day long
and you're not gonna
be able to convey that.
Language is an ideal medium
for conveying those kinds of experiences.
And I think that's the kind
of learning that kids get into
at the end of the first year of life
and throughout the preschool years.
And we continue to do
it throughout our lives.
But it's really central, I think,
to kids learning over the
course of the preschool years.
And it's just based on
fundamental assumptions
that people are social,
and therefore they will share
their experiences with kids,
but they also are agents
who act on objects.
And so they can share
experiences of objects
and they will act efficiently
so that when you see
what they choose to say
and what they choose not to say,
you can infer from that
what they see as relevantly
alike in the world,
and what they see is different,
what distinctions they
think need to be made
in the situation they're in
to be sharing experiences
within that situation.
Does that make any sense?
Okay, those are kind of the
general ideas about language.
- [Woman] Awesome, so students,
we're gonna go upstairs
to (mumbles)
but first, let's thank Elizabeth Spelke.
- Thank you all.
(all applauding)
(gentle music)